what i will say about this going through
this is that you've finished
a lot of shows that i've watched like a
few episodes of
and they're not going to be on my list
but you've like just straight up
finished them and scored them yes
i don't trust someone who would get
through some of these shows
i think there's something wrong
something's gone wrong in the head they
make you keep watching
you have to understand like back in like
2015 this is all i [ __ ] did like no
[ __ ] wonder you burnt out anime when
you're like what
when you're actually finishing most of
these shows yeah
you know in the movie old boy when that
guy is trapped in that room for like 10
years
like i'm pretty sure he watched less
anime than this like
like how do you okay yeah not gonna lie
like i'm looking through my list right
now and
like i i committed my past soul for the
fact that i finished infinite straddle
season two like
yeah you finished season one you went
through season two
that you didn't lie on any of these that
you know like okay uh legit
other than sazai-san i hundred percent
have finished all these all right well
[ __ ] yeah
and that is like i swear i didn't mind a
little [ __ ] reaction there say
[ __ ] but i swear i finished
i mean overall your list is like exactly
what i'd expected
yeah like you you give the shows that
are universally accepted to be good good
ratings right yeah
is the university to be bad bad ratings
yeah i mean i have good taste what can i
say
the public taste i don't think i have
the publicity
it's pretty in life i gave you a nice
three that's far from public taste yeah
you can't just
just do one that was your one whole take
i won't notice she gave charlotte to
seven
yeah and that's a pretty high score for
what i think yeah i would just in june
my eight is like worst piece of work
yeah i would give that realistically
like a fire would you say
if the director is esteemed or like the
showmakers are esteemed you're more
likely to give a fairer review
i think if i'm a fan of like the
the creator or like the studio or like
someone in the production team
then i'm more willing to give like you
know say like charlotte right like
that's my
june production and like i love
everything manager makes but so i gave
it a seven but realistically thinking
back on charlotte now
realistically i give it like a four or
five so this is why i'm the perfect
critic because uh i just don't know
anything so yeah
you don't like anybody i go into the
show and um i don't even know what the
[ __ ] the studio made this like let's
just watch
yeah exactly so it's like bones who's
bones what is bones you gave another
nine
yeah what
what no you don't stand by that right no
come on i would still give it like an
eight
oh yeah i really enjoyed it i don't care
what anyone says i really enjoy but then
again i'm a [ __ ] horror anime simp
so that's like an anagram for i have
[ __ ] taste
yeah that's what i like because there is
no good horror anime what do you mean
there's there's there's everyone okay i
mean that's
i risk my case that's this that's that's
a horror in the same way that like
[ __ ] monster is a horror you know
what i mean yeah monsters are
no that's that that's that's a horror
the same way that [ __ ] grave of
fireflies is horror like it's different
kind of vibe bro what are you talking
about you know
i mean it's not like it's scary scary
you know it's kind of like this i don't
know man i was pretty [ __ ] on edge
when i watched modern okay
it's unnerving but it's not like like
it's definitely not on the same
kind of genre as another which is just
final destination
the anime adaptation but even campia
yeah and
i like the campiness of it i don't know
i really enjoyed it i love my [ __ ]
like like to me another was like a
really good b
grade horror are you trying to defend
the [ __ ]
umbrella scene yes
how did you not burst out laughing when
that happened man
maybe because i watched it the entire
the entire last two episode
episode the entire last two episodes was
just a [ __ ] slapstick
yeah comedy might as well put some benny
hill music
on that [ __ ] i really love the campiness
of it i don't know why
all right all right [ __ ] that [ __ ] i i
completely get why people hate another i
thought i just thought it was really
like
tongue-in-cheek like camping right right
give me the box let me pull out the next
one all right so they're gonna be funny
if i pull out myself
all right